las presiones internacionales dieron
resultados y haití se prepara para una
transición de poder el primer ministro
interino cloud yusef dimitirá del máximo
cargo ejecutivo y será reemplazado por
ariel unr y quien había recibido el
respaldo expreso de la onu y de
potencias extranjeras
joseph por su parte integrará al nuevo
gobierno como ministro de relaciones
exteriores a falta de un anuncio oficial
unr y publicó un audio refiriéndose a sí
mismo como primer ministro e hizo un
llamado a la unidad nuestros hermanos
haitianos le dieron una oportunidad de
la paz mientras dejan la posibilidad de
que algún día la verdad pueda ser
restaurada ahora le toca a todos los
líderes nacionales caminar juntos en
unidad hacia un mismo objetivo para
demostrar que son responsables el sábado
el core grupo integrado por los
embajadores de alemania brasil canadá
españa estados unidos francia la unión
europea y representantes de la oea y la
onu había apoyado expresamente anri para
liderar la transición luego del
asesinato del presidente yo en el mois
el 7 de julio pasado la casa blanca
destacó el inminente pacto político en
haití
no hemos recibido una notificación
oficial a través de nuestra embajada
pero saludamos los reportes de que los
actores políticos haitianos están
trabajando juntos para determinar el
camino a seguir me transformé
henry había sido nombrado primer
ministro dos días antes de la muerte de
maurice pero no llegó a ser investido
por lo que josep había asumido el
ejecutivo interino el objetivo del nuevo
gobierno será convocar elecciones en un
plazo que rondaría los 120 días para
elegir a un nuevo presidente